this is a huge story I think when they
look back on this period this will be a
key component of it from Politico
Georgia Court posts then removes
document detailing charges against Trump
the document which which Reuters first
reported came from the Fulton County
Court listed 12 felony counts and one
serious felony count for violating
George's RICO Act
here's the thing the grand jury
is is still in they have been convened
how could they have these documents
ready to go many
they're suggesting that the Georgia D.A
planned to charge Trump regardless of
what the grand jury actually did
Politico says the county court in
Georgia where Donald Trump is expected
to be charged this week briefly posted
and quickly removed a document on Monday
detailing several charges against the
former president over his alleged
election interference in the state in
2020. the document which Reuters first
reported came from the Fulton County
Court includes Trump's name and lists
the cases that it says open it is dated
August 14th and time stamped 12 39 PM
the document lists 12 felony accounts
and a serious felony account for
violating their RICO Act this is crazy I
think we have the document right here
this is it case information state of
state of Georgia versus Donald uh John
Trump you've got the case number the
filing date
I'm just going to say this right now
if there is a filing date on a court
document listing charges I can say
definitively they filed charges against
Trump now guys I think we can get
semantic semantic or or a bit pedantic
and say perhaps filing a charging
document is different from literally
bringing charges against Trump but I
think the fact that they did this is
telling and no one is going to trust
them over this they've pulled this
document down they're issuing no comment
so
I don't I don't know what to think about
this but it certainly seems I don't know
man
I I'm calling it seditious conspiracy
that they're they were working to take
down Trump the grand jury which is
supposed to be the normal process to
bring about indictments is meaningless
fake and they were going to do this
anyway because their real goal is to
cheat in the 2024 election so just as
the common man here I'm a little I just
don't know the process very well but a
grand jury is going to get together and
they're going to talk about what to
bring What charges to bring and then
after they decide they'll build a paper
like what we have here this case
information document
um but you're saying that the grand jury
hadn't even decided yet and the document
was already prepared the grand jury just
finished hearing some testimony today
they were they're still in hearing
evidence so look again I'm not a lawyer
um but what I'm seeing from a lot of
high-profile personalities and people
who are literally lawyers is that it it
appears that they've filed charges
against Trump with the grand jury still
in session well the thing that's crazy
to me about it is even if you're gonna
like indict Trump ultimately if you're
gonna do what you're doing this is a
vicious thing you're trying to over do
this election interference as of this
will this is what would it be why would
you release this document and then pull
it back like why would you already mess
up like your everybody doesn't believe
you even more now when you come out and
you do these things and now you're gonna
like put out like some kind of mass mess
up like this it could be that they just
want to be like look how much control we
have like they're just dangling it
they're like you can't stop them you
think they're just being arrogant I
don't think they are but that would be
one possibility that they're like yo
we're just gonna commit crimes in plain
sight now and you can't stop us I worked
in politics I don't think they're that
smart to be quite honest with you that's
like they get if they had this plan and
I actually they will they could have
been they could have had this whole plan
to you know completely destroy Trump
already but and they messed up that's
another thing that politicians do all
the time they mess up consistently like
we see Bond do it pretty much every day
but like I just don't understand why
they would already release this and then
pull it back like I mean well they
screwed up obviously it can't it can't
be out there what I wonder is what
Trump's legal team is going to do in
response right because to be to to
basically imply no matter what he is
getting charged uh really raises
questions about due process he's not
even being indicted by a grand jury he's
being indicted by the lead prosecutor in
in Georgia which is crazy Mike cernovich
said Fulton County D.A indicted Trump
under George's RICO law Reuters obtained
the documents the grand jury is still
meeting the law isn't being followed
this is state-sponsored lynching Mike's
a lawyer
I mean so I can only imagine he
recognizes these documents but perhaps
there is some kind of uh argument I'm
trying to I'm trying to you know be
reasonable here maybe this is a list of
potential charges that are being
considered I don't know but I I don't I
don't know how they pop like it seems at
the if I was gonna be nice to these
people which I I absolutely would never
be they have a list of potential charges
that they said whoops over and published
yeah like it's like this is what we want
to charge him with let's hope the grand
jury goes for it so we'll have the
document ready to go as soon as they say
yes then we'll publish it well either
way they they probably like how we do
these things well how I used to do these
things we'd write two things and be like
this is what is probably going to happen
and one of these two things might happen
either way they click that button first
like that was the first one they clicked
so there no matter what they say there's
going to be a little Edge to like they
think this indictment's coming in the
way they think it's going to come but
then Reuters blamed uh the Georgia court
system they said oh the court this
document was up and then they took it
down and because this link you can see
in the URL is a is a Reuters Foundation
link so they're saying it's not that we
messed up as reporters it's at the core
are we not talking I thought we were
talking about the court system like
trying to subvert him not the not
Reuters correct that's what I think yeah
I mean I think both right like if
Reuters who released who published the
story first is saying the the court
system had it up and then took it down
that's interesting because then Reuters
knew to look for the document which why
would it be out if the jury hasn't
convened that's a really good point how
did Reuters get tipped off the document
was published unless it's possible that
because the grand jury is in they have a
reporter reporter just sitting there
hitting refresh non-stop on this court
listing page it's totally reasonable
well they probably they got a tip well
no uh Reuters actually I could be
totally wrong about this it's been a
very very long time since I had anything
ever to do with Reuters this is like 10
years ago when I knew a guy who worked
there my understanding is they they
actually archive and sell legal
documents oh really yeah so I mean this
might be right up their alley to say hey
look this document just dropped and then
GA was like how did this get published
whoops immediately took it down here's
what I gotta say if this document was
just a legitimate document pertaining to
the potential charges Trump is facing
they'd leave it up yeah there's nothing
to be afraid of and they would just say
this is the list of charges that the
grand jury is currently deliberating on
I think I I look man I'm not giving
these people the benefit of the doubt to
you if I was gonna if you were to ask me
what what is the reasonable solution the
simple system Occam's razor uh they
pre-planned charging Trump a long time
ago and the grand jury doesn't matter
and Georgia I feel like just has it out
for Trump George's I feel like then the
thorn in his side for so long so I'm not
really that's the other chart the other
cases seem a little bit uh more shallow
too this seems to be the big one I think
this is the one that people are really
worried about I think this is the case
that could really like destroy it well
the fabric of the government as we kind
of know it but why do you think that
it's just like this is the one that
could put Trump in actual jail right
that's what that's what people have been
telling me at least but maybe what do
you think it's not so much that this is
the one that can put them in jail it's
that this is the one where there are
zealous cult members who want to put him
in jail regardless DC is scared to
remind Trump New York is scared to a man
Trump the sheriff in Georgia already
said he's getting that mug shot there
they look man this is amazing
Republicans they're conservative
District Attorneys all over the country
they do nothing and now you've got this
novel reading of the law coming out of
Georgia where they say we are going to
indict the former president and the
current front runner for the Republican
party and Republicans are going oh gee
golly yeah and it's doing nothing and I
think Georgia wants this more than or
else they're one of the Swing States so
Democrats in Georgia want Trump to be
indicted there and solidly locked down
as a blue State for 2024. the other
thing that's interesting about this and
we were looking at the indictments this
is the fourth one right this is number
four I think every time it's it's the
it's the fourth jurisdiction to issue
indictments I think it's like the 78th
or something okay so I think every time
they've done this issuance like over the
I think they he's every time he's
fundraised he's just lost money each
time so I'm wondering how much money he
gets off of this one and if like that
really is like showing that his
support's gonna go down well it's an
issue of how much money do people have
so it's not that people aren't
supporting him anymore it's that a guy
who gets a hundred bucks a week in extra
cash already gave it to Trump can't give
it again yeah I think everyone has a
limit in terms of what they can give in
a political cycle especially you know a
year and a half out from the election or
less than a year and a half at this time
I mean I think it's pretty obvious what
they're doing they are they are one
trying to remove Trump's name from the
ballot trying to put him in jail to stop
him from running and saddling him with
with so much legal debt and paperwork
that he's unable to run anyway this is
cheating in an election period no
question you can remember this I hope in
a hundred years if they stumble upon
this podcast we said it they're cheating
they are targeting the front runner for
the Republican party that with the most
support who's set to win the primary in
in all of these ridiculous ways with
charges that are clearly bunk and
they're trying to reframe and rewrite
history to justify it yeah I mean
Trump's gonna have to campaign
completely around when he has court
appearances right all of 2024 which is
crazy to me on the other hand he has
such strong support from his base that
like if anyone could it's trump it seems
crazy that they're going to these
lengths to sort of slow him down uh but
today it seems farther than that it's
not just like meddling and trying to
make it hard for him it's they've
actually decided that he is going to get
indicted no matter what and that that
should make all of the voters you know
of both parties in Georgia angry
what do you guys think of this idea so
we threw this around the other day at my
office uh Biden uh complete like washes
Trump like what's it called
um he pardons Trump but Trump loses all
that momentum he gets from the
indictments all of a sudden the sanus is
back in the game what do you guys think
about that like if Biden decided that
you know but then he might be facing to
Santa so it's a terrible move on his
part but like like a curveball throwing
in there like what if he came out of
nowhere decided to Pardon Trump and all
of a sudden Trump's dead in the water at
that point I feel like I saw a video of
the Santa serving eggs to people and not
making eye contact with anybody like he
just looked like he was ashamed and
people like I'm just here for the eggs
one guy and people do that guy's he
already lost the race in my opinion I
don't think he has any chance how does
the campaign doing that like you're
gonna go have him serve eggs after he's
getting dogged all over the place like
uh it doesn't make him look like a cool
guy I know he should have been out
touring like Rama Swami is doing like
he's doing the basement Camp I mean it
seems like he's doing a basement
campaign I I haven't heard from him I
want to read this statement here this is
from Trump's lawyers
this was not a simple administrative
mistake Trump's attorneys Drew findling
and Jennifer little said in a statement
a proposed indictment should only be in
the hands of the District Attorney's
office yet it somehow made its way to
the clerk's office and was assigned a
case number and a judge before the grand
jury even deliberate okay that's false
then this is seditious conspiracy
against the United States happening in
your face in real time so do you file a
lawsuit now against the district
attorney file a lawsuit I know who do
you who files it
okay and also what court is going to
give Trump a fair trial in this country
that's the real question right he can be
indicted in any state obviously Georgia
has already made a decision about how
they feel about him like that's the
problem he has a judge already that's
why you have a federal government so
when States go Rogue like this you can
take care of them unless it's a mafia
cult and they're working for the big guy
and they're doing exactly what he wants
Joe Biden's federal government yeah Joe
Biden's federal government that's
already got multiple indictments against
Joe Biden's Chief political opponent
who's pulling above him I mean to your
point no I don't think Biden would ever
uh pardon Trump because I don't think
his base would be okay with that at all
I mean he is their their incumbent
candidate so he's their front runner in
a sense but he's not popular and he's
old and nobody really wants him there so
if he doesn't have enough uh Grace
within the party to Pardon Trump and
come off looking like oh you're standing
up for justice because a lot of his
supporters believe no matter what Trump
should go for go to jail they can't even
really name What charges they think he
should be convicted on that's why there
are so many you know it's like throwing
past that wall and seeing what will
stick there's whatever whatever works
they'll agree there's not a single
Conservative Republican libertarian or
otherwise
prosecutor in Georgia who is going to go
after what what this is I mean this is
at the bare minimum probable cause for a
conspiracy investigation yeah
and aren't they charging for some Rico
stuff too anyway so it's like a
conspiracy with a conspiracy like
they're doubling up
also like isn't Kemp the they're looking
Governor gonna say something I mean I
don't even know what to say if he has he
been charged or not because they fought
they've listed the charge like but he's
not the grand jury hasn't convened yet
so or hasn't decided on charges yet so
what's the process here do we who do you
we're supposed to be the greatest
country on earth like we're supposed to
have the best legal system and this is
the best like this is what we're dealing
with right now like in the middle of an
election cycle like but I think that's
why we have to say like Georgia is a
swing state this is a political move on
behalf of all Democrats in Georgia right
if they can be the ones to get charges
to stick against Trump to actually
convict Trump first they would love that
that would lock down Georgia as a blue
state in 2024 I mean this is strategic
and they're going to you know disrespect
Justice to achieve their political means
it feels like it's a it's super bowl or
like a football game right they're just
wanting to see their team win the crazy
thing is that apparently the DA's office
The Fulton County Court Clerk's Office
referred to a quote fictitious document
that has been circulated online
as if to argue
the document isn't actually from them
and it's being shared randomly yet
Reuters has Georgia Court website
briefly publishes removes document about
about potential Trump charges it's a
pretty serious allegation from them if
they're saying Reuters fabricated a
document and that's what's being
circulated online wow that's a bold
claim right that's their defense well
here's the story either
there's a seditious conspiracy against
Donald Trump using the court system or
Reuters fabricated the news to smear
opponents of Donald Trump and Reuters is
a wire service so like it's where's a
lot of news originates everywhere if
they're the ones fabricating the news
that would be deeply concerning so
should Reuters file a lawsuit against
the person who's claiming that they are
are you defamation I mean maybe yeah
just a lawsuit after a lawsuit it's like
lawsuits just for media because these
lawsuits don't get resolved for years so
like we're just sitting here it's so we
can freak out about it while they just
keep doing the same stuff it's insane
like and if you look at like what we're
going to impeach Biden now what's going
to happen then is that process going to
go through that's another what that's
kind of a lawsuit I guess not the same
thing all I want to talk about is
graphene and I'm talking about all I
want to talk about is fuel oh I want to
talk about energy costs because if we
want to circumvent a revolution of
violent or revolution we need to make
energy cheaper we need to make feel
cheaper I know politics I mean it's not
should talk about the only reason from
it's it's one of the strongest reasons
for Revolution and civil unrest lack of
access to Food Water Shelter Etc
but it's not the only reason I'm in
political instability of course even
when there is food available but it does
tend to be food and and uh of course
energy I want to point this out too
because we have this from Atlanta news
first that's interesting August 10th
this is being highlighted in much of
these stories we have an announcement
Fulton D.A Willis launches fundraising
website
yeah oh the D.A launched a fundraising
website to make money at the same time
these indictments are pre-published we
should check that we should check the
receipts on that I don't know when that
comes out but I'm sure there's going to
be a pretty penny in there I was trying
to track down this is she running for
re-election I was trying to track this
down but I think she's a quote where
she's like yes we've we've really
accomplished what we meant to or
something like she uses the word
accomplished I'm gonna be like what do
you mean you had a goal and you achieved
it that doesn't sound right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time